incroyable découverte qui passionne le
monde dollars 271 oeuvres inédites de
picasso sont apparus comme par miracle
la sphère des buts en 2010 pierre le
guennec un électricien à la retraite
décide de contacter la picasso
administration afin de faire
authentifier 271 oeuvres du peintre ses
oeuvres il les aurait reçu au début des
années 70 comme cadeau de la part de
jacqueline roque épouse de pablo picasso
on a donné vous voyez partir comme ça
avec la sous - c'est madame qui mena
mais si elle me l'a donné c'est que
monsieur parmi ses oeuvres des dessins
ou encore des lithographies daté de 1900
à 1932 et non signé par l'artiste
les héritiers de pablo picasso porte
alors plainte en 2010 contre
l'électricien son épouse pour recel
mon père ne changeait pas ses idées et
ne changeait pas ses habitudes et ne
changeait pas absolument pas il n'aurait
jamais donné autant de dessins d'un seul
coup en plus un électricien
en 2015 pierre le guennec et son époux
sont reconnus coupables de recel
les époux sont condamnés à deux ans de
prison avec sursis par le tribunal
correctionnel de grasse
qu'est ce que vous ressentez là
notamment à travers ça me reste en
travers un an plus tard
pierre le guennec change de version
selon lui jacqueline roque aurait donné
ses 271 oeuvres
après la mort du peintre en 73 la peine
est alors confirmée par la cour d'appel
d'aix en provence en 2016
quand on écoute la vérité qu il dit à la
cour
eh ben pour moi cet arrêt de la cour
d'appel d'aix-en-provence est un immense
gâchis
et c'est une catastrophe en 2018 la cour
de cassation a annulé cette condamnation
selon elle il n'y aurait pas de preuve
du vol de ses oeuvres
l' affaire a été renvoyée devant la cour
d'appel de lyon
[Musique]